doing poetry opens me up and it makes me
feel
just a little bit stronger because it's
something that
i'm more comfortable with so
i'll give you a poem since a lot of
people
were wanting some more of my poetry and
wondering if that was the only one so
if i could have god take one thing away
from me
that i would give away my sexuality
now man nor woman is what i would be
now what would this world want for me
you see everybody thinks that i'm lying
when i say that i don't
but i'm really lying when i do you see
when i'm with a man
i pretend that he loves me that he
adores me
that he is the only one that i can make
him feel this way
but then when it's all over and he's
gone
and i'm paid i think at least he left
something behind
that i could buy something that i really
want
the way that he bought me you see that
was the reality
of my sexuality okay just
don't tell me just leave me alone
because this one hurts
this one really hurts this one
really hurts and
i wrote this
by looking at a picture of a black woman
an older woman and
she was standing in front of the
american flag
and i don't know i kept looking at this
picture
hi or what the whatever and i came up
with this and i grabbed
whatever i don't know what it was but
once i write it
i'm always going to remember and when i
looked at this picture i looked into her
eyes
it said to me look into her eyes
and read the story of a woman's
pain her pride her fight for glory
you see when the invitation for freedom
came
it did not bear not one woman's name
no longer to be slaved by one man
now she was caged by three
and these are men that she called family
you see her father gave her weakness
and her brothers gave her pain and the
only gift her husband gave her was his
family name
you see freedom was something that she
had never known
because she was taken from her home
before she was quite grown
you see she's watched the sand fall from
the hourglass of her life
and she feels empty and she was
wondering has she ever been full
because sexism and racism
these are things that she had to fight
but it was a battle
she never back away from because she
believes in what's right
and this cold world would never give her
a thing
but fear of what tomorrow would bring
but the mystery of tomorrow it would
stay
that way cause fight she would
every day and when the men of the world
try and push her down
her feet never leaves the ground she
stares her enemy in the face
and she tells him in freedom all women
have a place
and who are you to take freedom from me
you may stay strong and sell it as a
tree
but as a woman i am the earth
and without me no tree would
ever be
i'm just debating
okay you're so good you better go
you're so good darling thank you your
poetry is so good
and you know what i come here because
i'm fighting for a reason i want to be
the success story
i want to be the one that i'm old enough
i've been there i've done that but i
want to
show them that with me i'm not coming to
ask him for
nothing that he can't happen
just one little push run like hell
i will be a success story i will show
this
world by myself i'm not married
and this is a fake ring oh oops i don't
blow myself out the water
but with without it i will be the
success story
for myself and i'm just glad
that you gave me an opening for the
world to say guess what if you keep on
loving me it makes me work harder
everybody pray that
girly girl gets that house
in the front yard to play in the
backyard to swing though
and with that i say toast
thank you girl gotta go